das us-verteidigungsministerium hat
jetzt mehrere super mysteriöse videos
offiziell auf seiner internetseite
veröffentlicht es handelt sich um
aufnahmen von verschiedenen marine
piloten der us navy
die unbekannte flugobjekte zeigen also
was steckt wirklich hinter diesen
rätselhaften aufnahmen klicks um science
im future die gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannendes heinz videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen clixoom gibt es übrigens auch
als podcast für unterwegs die links
spotify und apple podcasts sind hier
unten in der video beschreibung
die aufnahmen entstanden bereits vor
einiger zeit nämlich vor 16 2004 und vor
fünf jahren 2015 vor drei jahren also im
jahr 2017 wurden sie dann von der new
york times gelegt wir haben so berichtet
und jetzt sind sie eben sogar offiziell
vom pentagon veröffentlicht worden
handeln sie sich um ufos die da in den
usa gesichtet worden sind
kampfjetpiloten jedenfalls treten als
zeugen auf die cbs news berichtete
wurden einige dieser flugobjekte über
wochen beobachtet und dann hatte man
sich entschieden zwei us kampfpiloten
loszuschicken um die sache ein für
allemal aufzuklären die beiden piloten
berichten wirklich erstaunliches demnach
wollen sie das mysteriöse objekt etwa 15
meter oberhalb der wasseroberfläche
draußen im pazifik aufgespürt haben
es sei nicht nur rund 13 meter lang
sondern habe sich auch in einer
unvorstellbaren geschwindigkeit vorträgt
allerdings erst als die piloten sich
immer weiter näherten dazu einer die
piloten in einem interview mit der times
es beschleunigte sich wie nichts was ich
jemals gesehen habe
die piloten seien dann weiter zu ihrem
treffpunkt geflogen etwa hundert
kilometer entfernt dort entdeckten sie
das objekt dann wieder demnach muss es
die strecke in sehr kurzer zeit
zurückgelegt haben der ehemalige pilot
david fray war hatte das video vor 16
jahren aufgenommen er berichtet als ich
ihm nahe kam hatte schnell richtung
süden beschleunigt und ist in weniger
als zwei sekunden verschwunden
seine bewegung sein zitat extrem abrupt
gewesen und habe ihn an ein zitat
tischtennisball der von einer wand
abprallt erinnert 2015 ereignete sich
wohl ein ähnlicher vorfall haben
zwei piloten ebenfalls flugobjekte
entdeckt die nicht eindeutig zu
identifizieren waren in der aufnahme
hört man sie ganz erstaunt rufen es ist
eine ganze flotte ihren erzählungen
zufolge war sie objekte gigantischer
geschwindigkeit gegen die windrichtung
gerast und über die wasseroberfläche
rotiert in us medienberichten
die kampfpiloten dass sie während ihres
trainings einsatzes auf dem
flugzeugträger theodor roosevelt immer
wieder unbekannte flugobjekte über der
amerikanischen ostküste gesichtet haben
wollen jeden tag seien die objekte in
der luft gewesen und das über einen sehr
langen zeitraum von bis zu zwölf stunden
sie sprechen von einer hyper
schallgeschwindigkeit in bis zu 10.000
metern höhe und das ohne sichtbaren
antrieb auch abgaswolken hatten die ufos
demnach nicht hinter sich hergezogen
nach ansicht der piloten ist eine sache
ganz klar
menschen können nicht dahinter stecken
denn dafür sei die beschleunigung viel
zu unvermittelt passiert und das in
einem raschen wechsel mit abrupten stopp
dazu sagt der pilot ryan place in einem
interview mit der new york times
geschwindigkeit bringt dich nicht um
anhalten bringt dich um oder
beschleunigung auf der anderen seite sei
es nicht ihr job über außerirdische zu
spekulieren so die piloten in dem
interview sie könnten nun berichten was
sie an der us-ostküste mit ihren eigenen
augen gesehen hätten es sind tatsächlich
zwei piloten die sich in dem interview
mit der new york times vor drei jahren
2017 mit ihrem richtigen namen zitieren
lassen drei weitere piloten werden
anonym behandelt doch alle sind sich
einig darin dass die objekte 2014 2015
fast täglich zu sehen waren ende des
jahres 2014
aber dann kam es fast zu einer kollision
zwischen einem piloten und einem der
seltsamen objekte und es wurde ein
offizieller bericht eingereicht um den
vorfall zu klären die new york times
hatte damals nicht nur interviews mit
den piloten gemacht sondern außerdem
auch ein geheimes programm des
us-verteidigungsministeriums öffentlich
gemacht dieses forschern bereich der
sogenannten unerklärten luft phänomene
und sei mit einem hohen millionen budget
ausgestattet sodass recherche ergebnis
das pentagon hatte das daraufhin
bestätigt aber zudem auch klar gemacht
dass dieses programm nur von 2007 bis
2012 gelaufen sei dennoch ermittle man
auch weiterhin wenn über ufos
berichtet werde jetzt viele jahre später
ist das pentagon offensichtlich mit der
prüfung der aufnahmen fertig man habe
sich jetzt entschieden die videos von
offizieller seite aus zu veröffentlichen
sie werden fleur gümbel und coface
bezeichnet die sprecherin des pentagons
erklärt dass man mit dieser
veröffentlichung missverständnisse in
der öffentlichkeit klären wolle
deswegen habe sich das
verteidigungsministerium der vereinigten
staaten dazu entschieden die videos zu
veröffentlichen denn noch erklären die
verantwortlichen das zitat die in den
videos beobachten flug phänomene
weiterhin als nicht identifiziert
eingestuft werden also ufos aber ufo
heißt eben nicht alien raumschiff
sondern nicht identifizierbares
fliegendes objekt an identifies flying
objects auch aus der apollo-mission ufos
gesichtet dort war es immer material was
die kapsel verloren hatte aber eben
nicht allen raumschiffe ganz wichtig
wenn von elian raumschiffen die räte ist
klar ist die aufnahmen sind nicht neu
sondern kursieren schon seit einigen
jahren im netz dennoch treibt die
veröffentlichung die spekulationen noch
einmal an die wellen in den sozialen
netzwerken schlagen hoch ein
twitter-user schreibt zum beispiel tus
hausen twenty ist so fucking wild das
pentagon just computers and berlin news
was sollen wir mit diesen videos jetzt
anfangen gelten sie als neue hinweise
auf außerirdisches leben vieler
fachleute sind sich mittlerweile sicher
dass wir nicht allein im weltraum sind
selbst die nasa geht davon aus dass wir
so oder so in einigen jahren auf
außerirdisches leben stoßen werden doch
noch immer fehlt der endgültige beweis
doch bei astrophysikerin und
astrophysikern bei astrobiologen und
biologin steht die suche nach mikroben
auf fernen planeten im fokus und nicht
solche ufo-sichtungen wie sie derzeit
die runde machen bei ufologen
verschwörungstheoretikern und science
fiction fans weltweit dagegen ist es
eine geheime militärbasis die area
verwandten im us-bundesstaat nevada ist
area 5 gewann ein ufo landeplatz oder
ein testgelände für geheim jets in den
90er jahren trat ein angeblicher zeuge
im us fernsehen auf demnach nur die
us-regierung area 5 gewann
als location nutzen um mit einer grauen
außerirdischen spezies in kontakt zu
treten und technologien auszutauschen
die aliens hätten sehr kleine münder
nasen dafür aber extrem große köpfe und
augen daraufhin gab es einen
regelrechten ufo und alien hype werden
dort schlimme alien experimente
durchgeführt ist die area 5 gewann die
spielwiese für tests auf unserer erde
seriöse expertinnen experten bezweifeln
dass die anlage werde zwar zur erprobung
neuer technologien genutzt diese seien
allerdings alle irdisch oder und weil
dort viel unter der erde passieren aber
auf keinen fall außer dass die
massenhaften ufo sichtungen in der
region seien alle mit vielen flugzeug
experimenten zu erklären und insider
behaupten sogar dass die
verantwortlichen der area fifty waren
solche verschwörungstheorien sogar ganz
lieb sein denn diese würden die menschen
von den tatsächlichen geheim projekten
ablenken so würden ab und an auch extra
lasershows abgehalten um die ganzen uwe
jäger in der region weiter zu verwirren
und auch der zeuge von damals robert
lazar entpuppte sich schnell als
unglaubwürdig seine angeblichen
universitätsabschlüsse waren erfunden
zudem zeigten andere physiker dass er in
sachen ufo bau nur wenig ahnung hatte
dennoch sind natürlich auch weiterhin
zahlreiche privatpersonen auf der suche
nach außerirdischem leben viele stützen
sich dabei auf das projekt ufo stalker
bei dem sich jeder als augenzeuge
mysteriöse objekte am himmel eintragen
kann
die interaktive karte selbst
funktioniert ganz einfach wann und wo
wurde das unbekannte flugobjekt
gesichtet und wie sah es genau aus
diesen informationen kann jeder
augenzeuge auf der website ufo stalker
eingeben wenn möglich dann sogar mit
einem beweisfoto dann wird eine
fallnummer erstellt und der sichtung
sword sowie die kommentare des
jeweiligen augenzeugen werden in die
datenbank gespeist und es werden
tatsächlich daten aus der ganzen welt
aufgenommen
doch user können nicht nur ihre eigenen
ufo-sichtungen eingeben sondern sich
auch anschauen ob und wann außerirdische
in ihrer nähe entdeckt worden sind die
ufo symbole der interaktiven karte
müssen dafür ganz einfach angeklickt
werden und schon werden die mehr oder
weniger detaillierten berichte angezeigt
anfang juni hat beispielsweise ein user
eingetragen dass er in berlin ein ei
förmiges ufo gesichtet habe ein foto
jedoch lieferte er nicht dazu
die sichtungen selbst lassen sich nach
beliebigen kriterien filtern zum
beispiel nach
region monat tag oder jahr dabei
scheinen die meisten berichte im sommer
einzugehen vor allem im juli scheinen
sich demnach besonders auf seltsame
phänomene am himmel abzuspielen dieses
projekt basiert auf dem elektronischen
fall bearbeitungsprogramm der
uno-organisation move on case management
system blue von steht für new deal ufo
network und hat ihren sitz in den usa
eines der hauptziele die öffentlichkeit
über das ufo phänomen und die möglichen
auswirkungen auf die gesellschaft zu
informieren von selbst gibt an dass sich
freiwillige foto analysten das
beigefügte bildmaterial anschauen und es
dann auch analysieren so heißt es auf
der webseite
sie verwenden eine reihe von
verschiedenen techniken um die
authentizität eines fotos oder videos zu
identifizieren und zu versuchen eine
meinung darüber abzugeben ob es sich um
eine echte oder um eine fälschung
handelt und um den ursprung des objekts
auf dem foto super spannend ist das
ganze keine frage
dennoch steht auch fest dass dieses
projekt nicht wirklich wissenschaftlich
ist schließlich gibt es keine
ausschlusskriterien nach denen die
meldungen ausgesiebt werden jeder
wirklich jeder kann berichtete beitragen
so ist es natürlich klar dass es sich
wenn überhaupt bestimmt nicht bei allen
meldungen um außerirdische handelt denn
schließlich gibt es viele andere
erklärungen für seltsame erscheinungen
oder lichter am himmel das wetter meteo
schauer oder beispielsweise flugzeug
tests oder starling von ihnen musk ja
die können dahinter stecken es gibt
viele fachleute die ufo sichtung auch
mit technischen fehlern oder
neurologischen überlastungen der piloten
erklären so auch der astrophysiker leon
golub im interview mit der new york
times vermutete der technische fehler im
code für die bildschirme mich erinnert
das an eine uralte science fiction
geschichte von stanislaw lem da jagen
astronauten auch ufos im weltraum
hinterher und verschwinden dann im
unendlichen am ende war es genau das
eine ladung im monitor damals in science
fiction gab es noch röhrenmonitor die
dort hin und her flog oder wenn es
videos oder fotos von unbekannten
objekten gibt könnten diese oft durch
vögel oder insekten erklärt werden die
in einem speziellen winkel heranfliegen
aber auch linsen reflektionen im
objektiv sind oft verantwortlich für das
was man dort angeblich sieht wenn man
selbst ein unbekanntes objekt am himmel
entdeckt kann man sich beispielsweise
bei der deutschen flugsicherung melden
zudem gibt es in deutschland drei
vereine die ihre arbeit nach
wissenschaftlichen grundsätzen richten
sie sind in den theorien eher skeptisch
gegenüber und verstehen sich als
anlaufstelle für die menschen die
antworten suchen und mysteriöse sichtung
melden wollen es handelt sich um die muh
von cs ein europäischer ableger des
youtube networks in den usa außerdem
auch am start die deutschsprachigen
gesellschaft für forschung und die
gesellschaft zur erforschung des ufo
phänomens ev nach der sichtung werden
fragebögen ausgewertet und manchmal
werden sogar spuren gesichert dann wird
analysiert wie das wetter an diesem tag
war und welcher flugverkehr
stattgefunden hat meistens gibt es dann
auch eine erklärung für das was man
gesehen hat nur in vier bis fünf prozent
der fälle bleibt offen was die menschen
wirklich gesichtet haben oft sind es
sterne oder sternschnuppen aber auch led
helium ballons oder beleuchtete drohnen
sind in vielen fällen die
schlussendliche erklärung für die ufo
sichtung an dieser stelle muss auch noch
einmal deutlich darauf hingewiesen
werden dass ufos erst einmal nichts mit
außerirdischen lebens zu tun haben klar
ist dass bislang immer noch der letzte
beweis dafür fehlt das es überhaupt
außerirdisches leben gibt und dabei geht
es der wissenschafts community eben
nicht um lebensformen die möglicherweise
sogar fliegende objekte bauen und
bedienen können sondern erst einmal um
winzige mikroben und bakterien auf
fernen planeten dass es sich bei den ufo
sichtungen tatsächlich um außerirdisches
leben handelt das sich mit hyper
schallgeschwindigkeit vor bewegt ja das
ist mehr als fraglich aber ganz von der
hand weisen können wir es nicht wenn es
eben doch außerirdische werden die
darauf warten dass wir den warp antrieb
erfinden und sich erst dann wirklich
zeigen werden so wird es ja in star trek
prognostiziert mit der erfindung des web
antrieb sehr mit
überlichtgeschwindigkeit fliegen kann
werden mehr mitglied der vereinigten
föderation der planeten
trotzdem die wahrscheinlichkeit
außerirdisches leben aufzuspüren ist
wahrscheinlich sehr viel höher wenn wir
uns weiter auf konkrete forschung
konzentrieren wo wir auch wirklich
hinweise haben beispielsweise die
analyse der atmosphäre von exoplaneten
die erforschung des mars oder von saturn
zum beispiel pentagon veröffentlichten
bilder aliens auf der erde anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren und zwar diesen
kanal klick zum science and future bis
dann bleibt dran